das waren eindeutig falschmeldung
gestern da war von einem sturm auf die
krankenhäuser nächste woche die rede die
welle der infizierten werde wie ein
tsunami über sie hereinbrechen usw
doch das ist einfach nur falsch die lage
ist durchaus extrem ernst und ein
kollaps des gesundheitssystems steht zu
befürchten aber eben nicht nächste woche
das dauert noch etwas und man kann das
datum gut eingeheizt und klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
jeder daten gekracht und neue zahlen
analysiert daran kann man sehr gut sehen
warum die regierung noch absolut nichts
über eine aufhebung oder lockerungen der
massnahmen sagen kann und wie die
kliniken dem moment ausgelastet sind und
auch sehr gut wann ihre kapazitäten
überschritten werden also erst mal die
entwicklung der fallzahlen und da gibt
es erst mal nicht so gute zahlen die
täglichen neuinfektionen steigen im
moment wieder ungebremst nach dem bis
mitte der woche die tendenz eher nach
unten gingen das heißt die tägliche
steigerung der zahlen sank blieb sie
jetzt die letzten tage konstant bzw
stieg sogar am freitag also gestern auf
17,7 prozent wir beziehen uns dabei auf
die zahlen der johns hopkins university
um die datenkonsistenz zu halten in
dieser situation kann nichts an den
bisherigen maßnahmen geändert werden
erst wenn dieser wert deutlich nach
unten geht in den einstelligen bereich
oder besser auf null
dann kann reagiert werden erst dann
rückt die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems deutlich nach hinten
in die zukunft oder kann sogar ganz
vermieden werden und wie die lage da ist
kann man jetzt sehr genau sehen und da
sind wir nächste woche noch meilenweit
von einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems entfernt die meldung
über einen sturm oder ein tsunami die
habe ich jetzt leider nicht gestattet
sondern nur noch hier im verlauf und das
ist einfach quatsch gewesen und so ist
die lage tatsächlich am donnerstag
wurden 525 cupid 19 erkrankte
intensivmedizinisch behandelt am freitag
waren es 139 wenn wir nach den
bisherigen erkenntnissen davon ausgehen
dass rund fünf prozent auf der
intensivstation behandelt werden müssen
beziehungsweise beatmet werden müssen
dann laufen die zahlen den aktuellen
fallzahlen acht tage hinterher sprich
entweder dauert es im schnitt vom ersten
test bis zu schweren symptomen acht tage
oder schwere symptome treten anteilig
doch deutlich später auf und es könnte
noch ein umstand hinzu kommen es könnten
fälle nicht gemeldet worden sein alles
ist möglich spielt in der jetzigen phase
aber keine so große rolle weil es sich
immer nur so um +12 tage handelt später
beim erreichen der höchster wenn der
anstieg gestoppt worden sein sollte dann
ist es entscheidend denn dieser umstand
entscheidet über das maximum der
schweren fälle so oder so poliert die
anzahl der behandelten aber mit den
ansteckungen so dass für die prognose
für das erreichen der kapazitätsgrenze
die zahl der täglich behandelten
entscheidend ist und da kommen wir für
die kommende woche eher auf niedrigere
zahlen demnach werden wir am freitag
nächster woche 2076 kurve 19 krank haben
die intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
müssen die tendenz geht dabei im moment
eher nach unten
demgegenüber stehen im moment sieben
1412 gemeldete intensivbetten nach dem
jetzigen stand es wird davon ausgegangen
dass 20 noch nicht gemeldet sind es also
fast 10.000 freie betten gibt dazu
kommen jetzt doch erst die ersten neun
beatmungsgeräte und es gibt überlegungen
beatmungsgeräte von tierärzten und aus
rettungswagen dazu zu nehmen sodass hier
relativ schnell 20.000 plätze geschaffen
werden können der engpass denen es noch
zu beheben gibt der ist das personal das
die geräte bedienen kann allerdings und
da sieht man mal wieder die extrem hohe
dynamik einer exponentiellen kurve so
oder so passiert das mitte april nach
den heutigen zahlen also erst mitte
april kann es zum kollaps kommen egal ob
wir zehn oder zwanzig 1000 betten haben
in erster fall ist es der 13 april im
weiteren der siebzehnte april damit die
kapazitätsgrenze des deutschen
gesundheitssystems also nicht
überschritten werden ist die einzige
wirklich wirkungsvolle methode kontakt
zu vermeiden zu hause zu bleiben
niemanden treffen mehr beatmungs plätze
entscheiden dann nur noch über ein paar
tage luft kontakt sperren können aber
die katastrophe als einzige maßnahme
also als absolut einzige maßnahme
verhindern ansonsten ist sie
unvermeidbar
früher oder später das kommt noch darauf
an wann welche zahlen gemeldet werden
wie dynamisch dann im anschluss die
entwicklung ist usw
sofort aber nächste woche das ist
wirklich mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit
so wird es noch keinen kollaps geben
aber trotzdem also bleiben sie gesund
stay home unbedingt zu hause bleiben
keine kontakte bis dann bleibt dran